welcome everyone can you hear me so it's
my pleasure to introduce to you your
speaker for this morning eric said
Rudolph who is a master student in de
maiz and he Eric received his bachelor's
degree in biology from the University of
Oregon in 1992 and then he moved on to
working with the zebrafish model
organism database he was a scientific
curator and ontology developer for them
and currently in addition to working on
his master's degree he works on two
separate program projects he's a
developer for the quantitative imaging
pipeline informatics working group in
the knight Cancer Institute and he's
also involved in what's called the Zen
based project which is based in
Cincinnati and is an online database of
frog genetics and genomics and this
morning eric is going to give his
pre-proposal defense he's going to talk
to us about how can an interactive
visual analytics tool help biomedical
scientists investigate
genotype-phenotype relationships good
morning everyone can hear me okay and
thank you Beth yes I will present my
thesis project proposal VA a study of
how an interactive visual analytics tool
can help users investigate relationships
between genotypes and phenotypes the
objective of this presentation is to
first give you some brief examples of
how we view biomedical data in
informatics tools and databases
specifically data related to genotypes
and phenotypes and illustrate a
challenge that we face I will then give
an overview of the
the aims of the project followed by my
proposed plan for achieving those aims
which will consist of prototyping and
evaluating user interface features in a
visual analytics tool I'll talk briefly
about the expected outcome and the hope
for benefits of the study followed by a
proposed timeline for doing the work now
seeking biologic
e
no it's it's supposed to it's a poster
app
yeah it's better thanks technology
okay seeking biological insights into
the relationship and distinction between
phenotype or the observable traits of
organisms above the molecular level and
genotype or the genetic makeup of
organisms that is inherited from their
parents has long been fundamental to
many areas of life sciences and today
there is a vast and growing wealth of
information about genetics genomics
phenotypes embryonic development in a
variety of biomedical and mono organism
databases and these data present
researchers with a great opportunity to
uncover human disease mechanisms and to
drive discovery of new therapies
provided that they are able to make
sense of extremely extremely large
amounts of information currently we lack
suitable bioinformatics tools to enable
investigators to effectively meet that
challenge but there are visual analytics
approaches however that can provide
insight and inspiration that will make
these interconnected data better
understood and what I want to do is
investigate how interactive user
interface features can help users
investigate genotype and phenotype data
and begin to synthesize insights from
what they find the my goal is to
identify and test a set of interactive
features user interface elements that
have the potential to enable
investigators to navigate this kind of
data in a web-based interface in such a
way that they can start developing
mental models and hypotheses about
underlying human disease mechanisms what
I propose to do to do with guidance from
two initiatives involving bioinformatics
research groups at ohsu whom I'll talk
more about in a bit is to carry out a
qualitative assessment and usability
study
an interactive visualization prototype
design of which will be based both on
these groups expectations and needs for
the visualization tool as well as
through user interface requirements
analysis now there are a lot of
resources and interfaces out there
already for this kind of data I'll
present a couple of examples the model
organism databases have been around for
a relatively long time and I've worked
as a curator for a couple of them and
they're wonderful resources that contain
an enormous amount of genetic genomic
phenotypic data about animal model
species like the zebrafish and mouse and
rat and frog their web interfaces are
primarily text-based as you can see in
this example where you may have to sift
and click through a lot of pages to find
information you want so it's a challenge
to to navigate all of these data and all
of these types of data if you want to
form some overall picture of the biology
associated with whatever it is you're
interested in you say a gene or a
phenotype this is something that's been
developed more recently it focuses on
one type of data it's a visualization
widget developed by the monarch a niche
initiative which is a project i'll
discuss a bit more shortly it's a
phenotype comparison grid with the
phenotypes associated with a human
disease listed in the Rose human
diseases listed in the Rose and
corresponding Mouse genetic models in
the columns little cells are shaded and
colored in order to indicate similarity
between the phenotype and the
corresponding model and I don't want to
concern is with the details of how this
works and it's
just intended to provide an example of
how you can start to include elements
like color and filtering and interactive
elements to explore these data in one
place and what my project entails
fundamentally is exploring how these
kinds of dynamic interactive elements
can be applied to making sense of the
great variety and volume of related
biomedical data that I touched on on the
previous slide type that's comparable
between mouse and humans or is it
looking at we know the gene that causes
this phenotype in humans and what
phenotype does that same gene causing
mice so is it more you're matching
phenotypes or you're matching genotypes
on that it's matching phenotypes between
so mice can have like high foreheads are
hmmm yeah okay or something some Simone
Simone dollar yeah now I guess exactly
okay so here I want to look at a real
example of the interconnectivity of
several types of biological data it's
just to give you a little sense of the
richness of the data that's out there so
this is a diagram in the form of a
network graph the ill integrates some
human and mouse data about a disease
which is ALS and related genotypes and
phenotypes human data are indicated by
the light blue circles or nodes Mouse
data are shown as the yellow nodes and
the green nodes represent both human and
mouse some mammalian data labels on the
arrows tell you something about how the
nodes are related disease as related
types human phenotypes have similarity
to mouse phenotypes and so forth so you
have here a rich set of biological
relationships that you can traverse via
multiple paths between the human and
mouse phenotypes which are near the top
and the human genotype is down at the
bottom you can see how similar nodes can
be grouped such as phenotypes bound by
the boxes the take home message here is
that this is a pretty informative way of
picturing many types of interconnected
data related to genotypes and phenotypes
but keeping in mind that even all of
this amounts to only partial information
about one disease and it's just a sliver
of all the data that's out there so it's
a challenge to make sense of all these
data and relationships and and to create
this kind of visual picture with
existing tools and resources like the
traditional animal model databases so
why is that important it's important
because our tools should help
investigators form hypotheses about
genotype phenotype associations and how
they underlie human disease here's
another diagram in the same vein as the
previous one except it's more of an
abstract example so imagine that you
have a potential path from a phenotype
of interest at the top to a disease at
the bottom and that path is incomplete
and it's a path that would be complete
if there is a known confirmed direct
relationship some interaction between
the two light blue human genes number
one and two it may be that the two human
genes are known to be in the same
genetic or protein interaction pathway
or it may be that
orthologs of the human gene exhibit
similar human phenotypes or gene
expression patterns if you have the
ability to picture the data in this way
in in these contexts perhaps in one
place then this picture can potentially
lead you to formulate the hypothesis
that some critical functional
relationship between the two human genes
exists so in other words it's leading
you to really start synthesizing the
biology and developing a scientific
narrative and I'm going to come back to
this when I discuss my project plan in a
few minutes in preparation for my
project I was pointed to some very
interesting research by Barbara Morell
this papers from 2009 but is still very
relevant she she explored how future
bioinformatics tools might give
scientists the support they need to move
beyond conducting queries and vetting
results and classifying relationships in
moving beyond that into the realm of
forming mental models of the underlying
biology whether where they are
formulating hypotheses and telling a
scientific story her study concentrated
on protein-protein interaction networks
and tools to view those networks she
found that while existing tools did a
good job of supporting tasks related to
finding relationships of interest future
tools could potentially do more to
support tasks that let users gain what
she called causal insights into the
biological systems being studied she
referred to these as explanatory
analysis so it's a step beyond
exploratory analysis she identified
features in visualization tools that
scientists would have liked to have had
or liked to have seen more robustly
supported and that might have enabled
enabled them to start doing that kind of
explanatory analysis or synthesis and
what you see here is not the complete
list of interface features that she
identifies on her paper whether it's a
few examples that provide some
inspiration for the sorts of features
that I might put to the test in my own
project I'm interested especially in
prototyping interactive elements but
certainly some of the content related
features here could inform my designs as
well
and finally before I proceed to the
specific aims of the project there are a
couple of local collaborations that are
crucial to it the monarch initiative is
a collaboration between groups at ohsu
University of Pittsburgh and several
other institutions which plans to deploy
a web application the features Symantec
tools for users to navigate manipulate
and interpret the rich content provided
by animal model databases that I talked
about plans to develop a visual
analytics software environment for
exploring these data in addition Beth
here at ohsu is interested in among
other things visualization of functional
genomics data the snapshot you see here
on the right is from hit Walker which is
a tool that aims to integrate genomic
information with complementary
functional analyses in order to
prioritize sequence variants in cancer
and I'm going to lean on these two
groups to help me develop develop
specific use cases for visualization and
analysis of genotypes and phenotypes and
to help narrow down the set of
interactive elements that I want to
prototype this part of my work and i'll
also be discussing with them their own
expectations and perceptions at what
users want from these sorts of tools
because i think it will be interesting
to find out how those perceptions may or
may not differ from what users find that
that they want as they start tying these
things out
that's the overview of the the
background for this project we'll move
on to the research question and the aims
I've defined some aims to address my
research question which is how can an
interactive visual analytics tool help
biomedical scientists investigate
relationships between genotypes and
phenotypes I talked a moment ago about
examples of potential visualization
features that tend to the knots not
supported robustly in existing tools but
that may be useful for helping users
move beyond exploratory analysis and
into explanatory analysis what I propose
is a usability study where I identify
some use cases and then specifically
select a small set of interface features
and then try them out and in the scope
of this project I can't possibly test
out all of the possibilities but I
intend to focus on a few features which
working together in complementary
fashion might enable users to start
synthesizing biological narratives and
form hypotheses so let's go back to the
the diagram I discussed earlier is when
I speak of investigating links between
genotype and phenotype you might have a
tool that represents data like a network
graph if that's beneficial doesn't
necessarily have to be that but you
might not want to have a display that
shows all of the data that you have at
once which could be indecipherable if
you have a huge amount of it instead the
user may wish to start at one point like
a phenotype of interest or perhaps a
small sub network and then start
exploring by following interface cues or
being given information by what is
connected to it until they can start to
build up this sort of pick
of the data and it may impact us be hard
to get all the way to this stage but the
use cases that I developed to help
answer my research question will likely
be along those lines it may not be this
exactly but the idea is that you might
start at one point and then proceed from
there and see where you can go all right
Amy number one is to determine the
design of a visualization environment or
tool containing the interactive features
that I want to test and to refine the
study design and this will involve user
scenario development and initial
mock-ups of an interface along with
fleshing out the study design n number
two will comprise development of a
functional interactive prototype or
prototypes based on the mock-ups that
aim number three will be to carry out a
qualitative usability evaluation of the
prototypes and to ensure that they
satisfy accepted usability guidelines
and the users find it satisfying and
desirable to come back use
okay so let's look at the project plan
for carrying out the aims again aim
number one is to determine the design of
a visual analytics prototype that will
be subject to usability evaluation and
the key questions here are what are the
objectives in particular what do the
monarch and functional genomics
visualization projects want to provide
to users exploring genotype and
phenotype data and what requirements do
their projects aim to satisfy who are
the stakeholders and the potential types
of users or user groups what are the use
cases in which set of interface features
do I want to test and are they
technically feasible also want to
determine the evaluation criteria
meaning the questions that I want to
address and ask users in order to gain
insight into what they are thinking as
they are using the prototypes low
fidelity prototypes will be developed in
order to provide the basis for
subsequent interactive or software based
prototypes and what I mean here by a low
fidelity prototype is one that is done
by hand either either on paper or with a
drawing package on a computer and that
gives an indication of the user
interface look and feel but without
being fully functional the approach I
want to take with the early prototypes
or mock-ups is to develop user scenarios
and this means that entire interface
interaction scenarios will be
illustrated with one screen for each of
the steps that a user will go through as
they navigate data much like you might
create storyboards depicting a scene in
a movie this will be an iterative
process and these storyboards will come
out of brainstorming sessions with users
as they are recruited for the usability
study now describe those
users more in a bit this is an important
step because I think it will help convey
to the test users some of the
possibilities for what an interface for
investigating phenotypes and genotypes
can do it will help me discover what
they wanted to do in particular I'm
interested in the more advanced goals
that they might want to achieve with it
and that in turn will help me focus on
the handful of features that I want to
put in the subsequent prototypes now
based on the mock-ups and their initial
evaluation results I'll develop a
functional and interactive prototype for
further evaluation so that satisfies the
second aim and it will help confirm the
technical feasibility of putting the
interactive features into practice it
will be a high fidelity prototype which
in contrast to the low fidelity one will
be based on software it will be
functional it will be something that
users can actually interact with this
the this prototype will be constructed
using a JavaScript library called d3 or
data driven documents in a mock mock
data store with a subset of data needed
to support the prototype will be
obtained most likely from the monarch
project and i should add to that there
may be more than one prototype at this
stage if that's feasible and if it's
warranted by a need to demonstrate a
range of possibilities for what users
can do and in the process la meeeeee to
follow good general interface design
principles so the desired result here is
to put the interactive feature set in
action and to use some real genotype and
phenotype data from a real project
and with the third aim we come to a
usability evaluation of the prototypes I
propose that this evaluation which will
be based on widely accepted and
recommended methods can answer the
questions of whether the prototypes are
generally usable and inviting to the
user whether the selected interface
feature set is effective in practice in
facilitating explanatory data analysis
and whether there are unexpected
problems with the interface and
hopefully it will go a little better
than this the user interface evaluation
can be constrained by factors such as
time scales and the the ease of finding
participants and given the time frame
for masters project discount usability
engineering is an attractive alternative
to the more comprehensive evaluation
approaches such as quantitative analyses
that you might apply to an entire
interface discount usability evaluation
depends on a small number of users and a
small number of interface features and
for this sort of agile qualitative
approach or a few established inspection
methods that are especially useful then
I'll define and discuss these in more
detail shortly first is a heuristic
evaluation second involves a think allow
a think aloud method involving small
group of users and the third is a
semi-structured interview that includes
a simple usability survey and a
debriefing that takes place after the
think aloud sessions the low and high
fidelity iterations of the prototypes
will be subject to these evaluations so
i have to users performing erest
expectant in a different group of
perhaps five or six users will
participate in the think aloud sessions
and in
the survey and interview let's look at
each of these evaluation methods
individually the heuristic inspection
will be carried out based on Nielsen's
heuristics and I'll aim to recruit one
usability expert and one biomedical
domain expert to do the inspection then
these experts will focus on general
principles for interaction design that
you see here so Jakob Nielsen in like in
1995 established these general
principles for interaction design and
and it consists of broad rules of thumb
not specific guidelines and I won't go
into detail about all of these and easy
to find online if you search for Neil
sincere istics but I do want to say that
these guidelines were designed to apply
to all kinds of different user
interfaces they're out there in the
world so some of these items may be a
bit more relevant than others to this
project the for example i'd say that the
match between system and real world
where you want to make information
appear in a natural and logical order is
obviously important for a system that
strives to allow scientists to chart a
course from obtaining query results to
developing a bigger picture of the
biology and in addition to the ten
established points i will also want to
add to this evaluation a few points that
are specific to the biomedical domain
since this will be my chance to get
feedback from a biomechanical expert
user and developing those questions will
be part of the work that I do so I don't
know what they'll be yet that example
might be how well does the interface
convey the reliability or provenance of
the information that's shown which is a
critical point in a scientific context
now move on to the next method
the think aloud protocol will focus on a
few selected features and tasks so this
method will help gain insight into what
users are thinking as they are
negotiating the interface this
evaluation we can will be conducted with
users representing several defined
groups which I anticipate will be
students researchers and clinicians they
don't aim to have one or two users from
each group so in the think aloud walk
through the prototypes users will
attempt to carry out tasks corresponding
to the use case or the use cases that
will be defined during the prototyping
stages then the goal here is to
encourage users to do two things one is
to describe allow the actions that they
are taking and the other is to go a bit
beyond that and explain or interpret
their actions this method has been
described as one that gives you a window
on the soul of your users so I think
it's especially conducive to observing
how well they are synthesizing
information as they explore it I also
expect that this will gauge how well
users are able to efficiently and easily
navigate to data of interest and to
perform their analyses with a minimal
amount of help and whether the interface
effectively presents and communicates
biological information the final
inspection method involves a short
written survey and a debriefing
interview with each user this will help
capture general measures of the
prototypes usability it's called the
system usability scale it's a 10-item
Likert scale that provides a global view
of subjective assessments of usability a
few examples of which are shown here the
questionnaire will be given to each user
in the student researcher and clinician
groups after they've had an opportunity
to use the prototype
sin the think aloud sessions and after
this I will do a debriefing interview as
well to explore each user's reasons
behind their answers and there's a
formula to convert the responses to a
scale between one and 100 and based on
some research and further
experimentation with this approach it's
been proposed that a score of at least
68 to 70 or thereabouts-- corresponds to
the interface beam user-friendly and as
with the heuristic evaluation I also
want to add a few biomedical domain
specific questions and again the
specifics of these questions will be
determined as part of the work but the
intent is to help evaluate the
prototypes usability as specifically
scientific tools so what it proposed is
that visual analytics tools can be
leveraged by users to perform
explanatory analysis of genotype and
phenotype related data in to move beyond
exploratory analysis and begin to
synthesize a scientific story so the
outcome of the study will be a report of
my qualitative analysis of the
prototypes and their interactive
features i also want to produce a case
study and provide an in-depth
examination of how one of the users in
the study actually use the tool and what
worked for that user and what didn't
work I think that will shed light on
what users need and how those needs
compare it to our assumptions going into
this and I hope to come away with some
recommendations relevant to future
interface development and quantitative
evaluations of a complete system later
on then I hope that this study will have
a positive impact by contributing to
future progress of tools where
researchers and clinicians will be able
to
to decrease the difficulty associated
with complex biomedical problem
evaluation and to fully realize the
potential benefits of the the wealth of
data that's already out there and
already exists alright so that's my
project plan and expected outcome I'll
briefly go over the proposed timeline
for the work the table is broken out
into the specific aims aim number one
involves again the initial mock-ups and
scenario development recruitment of
users fine-tuning of the study design in
the evaluation protocols as well as IRB
approval for usability testing it would
take place over the next month and a
half I anticipate that aim to which is
the development of the functional
prototypes to require a month of work
then aim number three the usability
evaluation would proceed to
approximately the end of june and the
goal ultimately is to defend and finish
by the end of the summer and finally a
big thank you to my thesis Advisory
Committee Beth my thesis mentor and
colleague in the knight Cancer Institute
Melissa and Michelle here in de maiz and
Harry at the University of Pittsburgh we
might thanks also to colleagues at the
monarch initiative which melissa and
Harry are kopi is as well as those at
the the bis are and odg and thank you
all for watching and listening
yes thank you at an excellent
presentation it's a very complex topic
the question I have is what on your user
interfaces whether or not the emphasis
is actually on the usability of the
system or the presentation of the final
complete very complicated data in a
meaningful way it's really a blend of
both we obviously want more effective
tools but we also want to make sure they
go hand in hand with the accepted kind
lines that are out there and I think
it's it's especially important is for
the these kinds of interfaces to be
appealing so that people won't want to
come back to them and use them again
later on who are your target users for
this I mean basically use a tool that
was kind of at a different level and
asking different questions so do you
have a specific user that you're trying
to work with to develop your prototype
again it could be a variety but it's
Billy I mean any biomedical investigator
looking at the underlying basis for
human disease and researchers or
clinicians or clinicians who are going
to model organism databases to try to
find models for what's happening in
human and then trying to kind of make
sense of all of that I've noticed you
selected deeds
as your primary tool for building an
interface but I was wondering what
happens if you cannot fit the
affordances of the d3 development tool
to the design constraints that you might
discover an a.1 well that's something I
want to consider actually during aim one
where I'm selecting the features i'm
going to try to be mindful that it's
something that that's technically
feasible is at the same time i'm really
going to be having to learn a lot about
d3 on the fly so i guess just as a
follow up this is more just checking on
things but what will you do if you're
not able to design an appropriate
interface for aim 3 because you have
some dependencies that right at the very
least we'll have the low fidelity
mock-ups which are just hand drawn or
I'll use it drawing tool actually for
that and they'll be subjected to the
evaluation as well and then hopefully
though that will be able I'll be able to
transfer that to the more interactive
functional prototype but even if I run
into a lot of unanticipated trouble with
the more interactive software prototypes
will still have the the more crude
prototypes that can be subject to all of
those different kinds of evaluations so
you can still get some insight into what
users
I want to do in what they need to do as
long as the technology can support
it
it'll come out of discussions with users
as we recruit them then also discussions
with that Beth's group and the moderate
groups will be you know yeah it'll come
organically out of all that initial work
oh you'll be working with both the
monarch initiative yeah that's right oh
you think both school I think I want to
achieve something that had kind of costs
over has a crossover between what the
two groups are looking for and need but
not something that's so generic that
it's just going to be kind of irrelevant
hope that answered the question okay